UNCONSTITUTIONAL ABUSE OF POWER.
I'VE BEEN SAYING THIS ALL WEEK,
AND I'M GOING TO KEEP SAYING IT.
JOINING ME AND I WAS
ARI FLEISCHER, FORMER
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
ALSO WITH ME AS TOM FITTON,
PRESIDENT OF JUDICIAL WATCH.
ARI, LOOKING AT TRUMP'S LEGAL
TEAM, WHAT IS YOUR TAKE AWAY?
>> THEY ARE SUPERSTARS.
BUT ARE THEY SUPERSTARS WHO WILL
WORK WELL TOGETHER AND DIVIDE
THE LABOR APPROPRIATELY?
THAT IS THE REAL QUESTION.
THERE CERTAINLY HAVE BEEN GREAT
NAMES, LEGAL NAMES.
EACH HAVE STORIED HISTORIES.
YOU KNOW, A LOT OF THIS WORK IS
THE LEG WORK, GETTING
INFORMATION ON WITNESSES, TO
POKE HOLES AND WITNESS
TESTIMONIES IN CASE THE
WITNESSES ARE CALLED.
THAT IS A LOT OF HARD WORK THAT
IS GOING TO HAVE TO BE DONE IN A
SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME.
>> Laura: I THINK THEY HAVE
DIVIDED IT UP WITNESSED BY
WITNESS AN ARGUMENT BY ARGUMENT
FROM THE CONSTITUTIONAL TO THE
FACT BASED ARGUMENTS, SO I THINK
THAT IS ALREADY IN THE PROCESS.
TOM FITTON, WHAT WE HAVE HEARD
FROM THE MEDIA ARE SIP ALONE HE
IS NOT MEDIA PERSON, NOT A LOT
OF SEXY TRIAL WORK.
I GUESS TRYING TO RAISE
EXPECTATIONS, LOWER EXPECTATIONS
FOR HIM, BUT I LOVE THE FACT,
FULL DISCLOSURE, HE IS A CLOSE
FRIEND OF MINE, SO I KNOW HE IS
GOING TO BE FANTASTIC.
I LOVE THE FACT, HE IS KIND OF
AN ENIGMA TO THEM BECAUSE HE IS
NOT SOMEONE WHO SEEKS THE
LIMELIGHT.
>> ANY BASIC RESEARCHER
>> ANY BASIC RESEARCH INTO HIS
BACKGROUND, HE CAN HANDLE THE
SENATE IN THE PROCESS.
YOU CAN SEE WHY NANCY PELOSI
DIDN'T WANT THE SENATE TRIAL TO
HAPPEN, AND IT IS WHY SHE
OBSTRUCTED IT, BECAUSE NOW YOU
ARE GOING TO HAVE ALL OF THESE
POLITICIANS APPOINTED AS
IMPEACHMENT MANAGERS COME OVER
AND HAVE TO DEAL REAL LAWYERS
BUT I FEAR WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
A KAVANAUGH TYPE SITUATION.
IN THE ORDINARY COURSE, THE
PRESIDENT WILL BE VINDICATED IN
SHORT ORDER, SO THEY ARE GOING
TO THINK OF WAYS TO --
THEY SHOULD KNOCK A SCHIFF
OUTCOME HE IS A WITNESS, AND
THEY SHOULD CONSIDER PRELIMINARY
HEARINGS OUTSIDE OF A FULL
SENATE TRIAL TO LITIGATE THESE
ISSUES ABOUT PROSECUTORIAL
MISCONDUCT AND WHAT SCHIFF
DID.
>> Laura: THE SENATE SHOULD BE
DOING THESE TYPES OF THINGS.
IF THEY REALLY WANT THIS IN A
SEPARATE HEARING, NOT GOING TO
DO IT UNTIL AFTER IMPEACHMENT,
BUT THESE ARE QUESTIONS WE HAVE
BEEN ASKING.
AND ARI, BY THE WAY, DEMOCRAT
SENATOR JEFF MERKLEY THINKS
ANYONE TOO BIASED TO BE A JUROR
SHOULD STEP ASIDE.
>> GOING TO HAVE TO SEARCH THEIR
HEART AND ASK IF THEY ARE ABLE
TO SET ASIDE THEIR
PRECONCEPTIONS -- ALL OF US, ALL
100 OF US -- AND IF WE ARE
UNABLE TO DO THAT, IF WE ARE
UNABLE TO COME IN GOOD FAITH,
SAY WE WILL SET ASIDE OUR
PRECONCEPTIONS AND LOOK AT THE
EXACT LANGUAGE OF THE HOUSE
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT, THE
EXACT EVIDENCE AND HOW IT FITS,
THEN WE SHOULD RECUSE OURSELVES.
>> Laura: SO ARI, THAT IS HIS
INPUT ON THE JURY SELECTION PIER
2020 DEMOCRAT CANDIDATE IN THE
SENATE SHOULD ALSO RECUSE
THEMSELVES?
THE FORMER CANDIDATES,
SENATOR McSALLY SUGGESTED.
>> IT IS SUCH A JOKE ON ITS
FACE, BECAUSE THEY'RE TRYING TO
PRETEND THEY ARE A REAL COURT OF
LAW, THEY ARE NOT.
IF THE FOUNDERS WANTED TO PUT
THIS IN A REAL COURT OF LAW WITH
A REAL TRIAL, THEY WOULD HAVE
COME IN IMPEACHMENT HAVE GONE TO
A JURY.
IT'S NOT, 22 POLITICAL BODY.
WHAT'S GONE TO THE HOUSE, NOT TO
THE SENATE.
THE FRAMERS DIDN'T INTEND IT TO
BE POLITICAL BECAUSE THEY WANT
POLITICIANS ACCOUNTABLE TO THE
PEOPLE TO MAKE THE FINAL
DECISION ABOUT OVERTHROWING THE
PEOPLE'S DETERMINATION OF AN
ELECTION.
SO STOP ATTENDING THIS IS A
COURT OF LAW.
IF IT IS A COURT OF LAW, WHY ARE
THEY READING NEWSPAPER ARTICLES
ABOUT IT?
WHY ARE THEY APPEARING ON THE
TV?
JURORS ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO READ
ARTICLES ABOUT THE CASES IN
WHICH THEY ARE HEARING.
'S AREN'T ALL THOSE DEMOCRATS
WHO READ NEWSPAPER STORIES
BIASING THEMSELVES?
NO, BECAUSE IT IS NOT A REAL
TRIAL, NONE OF US SHOULD LOOK AT
IT THE WAY WE DO, AND THE
DEMOCRATS SHOULD STOP THIS SILLY
GAME.
NO ONE IS BUYING IT.
>> Laura: TOM, WE ALSO HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE THEY ARE
FLOATING MS. LEV PARNAS, WHO IS
AN ASSOCIATE OF GIULIANI'S,
WE WILL INTERVIEW
MAYOR GIULIANI ON MONDAY,
EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW HERE ON
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE," ASK MORE
ABOUT THAT.
BUT PARNAS HIMSELF, A BOMBSHELL,
CHANGE THE WHOLE TRAJECTORY OF
IMPEACHMENT.
REALLY?
>> I'VE BEEN CALLING IT THE
"GOSSIP GIRL" IMPEACHMENT.
PARNAS HAS MORE GOSSIP TO ADD
ABOUT THINGS WE ALREADY KNOW.
RUDY GIULIANI WAS CONCERNED
ABOUT CORRUPTION IN UKRAINE.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT THE NEWS
IS HERE.
PARNAS IS NOT PROVIDING ANY
EVIDENCE OF IMPEACHABLE ACTS BY
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
IT'S INTERESTING IN A
GOSSIP-ORIENTED WAY, BUT THE
IDEA THAT HE HAS ANY EVIDENCE TO
PROVIDE THE SENATE -- AND THAT
IS ONE OF THE BIG ISSUES HERE.
YOU TALK ABOUT A SENATOR SAYING
WE HAVE TO CONSIDER THE
EVIDENCE.
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY EVIDENCE.
>> Laura: RIGHT, NO, THAT'S
WHY THEY HAVE TO THROW THESE
LATE HITS FROM SOMEONE WHO
CLAIMS, ARI, TO READ THE
PRESIDENT'S MIND.
OH, TRUMP KNEW ALL ABOUT THIS.
HOW DO WE KNOW HE KNEW ALL ABOUT
IT?
WELL, IT'S HIS GUEST.
HOW DO WE KNOW WHEN THESE NOTES
WERE WRITTEN?
THERE'S NO CHAIN OF COMMAND OF
THE NOTES YOU HAVE TO DO IN A
TYPICAL LEGAL SETTING TO
AUTHENTICATE THAT THEY WERE
WRITTEN AT A CERTAIN TIME AND
MEANT A CERTAIN THING.
THERE IS AN ENTIRE PROCESS TO GO
THROUGH REGARDING SUCH TYPES OF
EVIDENCE.
AND BY THE WAY, THE FOREIGN
MINISTER OF UKRAINE HAD THIS TO
SAY, ARI, ABOUT PARNAS.
>> STRANGELY ENOUGH, MY NAME WAS
NOT MENTIONED.
FRANKLY, I NEVER SPOKE WITH HIM.
AGAIN, I DON'T TRUST ANY WORD HE
IS NOW SAYING.
>> Laura: HE DOESN'T TRUST ANY
WORD HE IS SAYING.
>> YOU KNOW, WHAT GAVE ME SO
MUCH DOUBT ABOUT WATCHING HIM IN
THESE INTERVIEWS, WHEN PEOPLE
START TO SAY EVERYONE IS IN ON
IT, IT HAD TO BE AWARE OF IT,
EVERYONE IS AWARE OF IT AND THEY
OFFER NO SPECIFICS.
THE VICE PRESIDENT WAS IN ON IT,
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL KNEW
EVERYTHING ABOUT IT, WITHOUT
EVER SAYING, IN A MEETING ON
SUCH AND SO DATE, SUCH AND SO
PLACE, THE VICE PRESIDENT WAS
INFORMED BY SUCH AND SO.
TOTAL LACK OF SPECIFICITY.
THESE SWEEPING GENERALIZATION
STATEMENTS THAT CANDIDATES MADE,
WITNESSES DON'T, BECAUSE HE
DIDN'T WITNESS THE SPECIFICS.
HE HAS NOTHING SPECIFIC TO
PROVIDE, AND THAT MADE ME JUST
SHRUG MY SHOULDERS AND SAY THIS
IS A GUY WHO CARRIES UP TO
EVERYBODY AND ANYBODY, TELLS
ANYBODY AND EVERYBODY WANT THEY
WANT TO HEAR.
HE DID IT WITH RUDY GIULIANI,
AND NOW HE IS DOING AT THE
DEMOCRATS, AND WITH THEIR